- Acquiring professional certificates
can be quite time consuming.
It can take quite a lot
of effort to get them.
So today, in this video,
I wanna inquire the question
what the most important certificates
for business professionals really are.
So, welcome to another coffee break
here on my channel Firm Learning.
My name is Heinrich
I'm a former McKinsey consultant
and on my channel I talk about
how to become successful in
the first years of your career.
So this video is informed by
my six years in consulting,
having seen lots of
companies in that time,
and I also asked you on
Instagram to get your opinion
what the most important
certificates are and why.
So all of this has been
gone into this video.
But to get some clarity
of what it is that I'm talking about
let's mention four areas
that I will not cover in this video.
And the first are very
regular university degrees
something like a bachelor,
a master, an MBA.
This is not what I will talk about.
This is not what I'm
considering a certificate.
Same is true for
professional certifications
that you just need to
work on a specific job.
This for instance is a bar exam in law.
I'm also not including a CPA or an ACCA
or any other accounting
certification like that.
Next, I will not consider certifications
that are very specific to IT.
So SAP certifications,
certifications from Google.
And finally, I will also
not include certifications
that are very specific to
just one sub-area of business,
something like a CPIM in supply chain
or a CMA in accounting.
And again, exception would be those
that are more broadly
recognized and applicable.
With that being said, let's
jump here into our tier list
With the S tier being the highest tier
and the D tier being the lowest tier
here in the rank that we are going to do.
And now let's start with certifications
from platforms like Udacity
or Coursera and so on.
And those for me are platforms
where you do get a certificate
through a structured online course
and there are some type of
examination logic in the end
where not everyone
necessarily gets a certificate
that goes over the curriculum.
And I'm placing these types
of certificates in the C tier.
And my rational here is that,
yes, often you learn
quite a lot of things.
It can be really helpful
Also myself once took a Udacity course
and I did learn a lot of things from that.
Though the truth is I would still argue
that these types of courses are not
that respected by employers.
There's not really the
perception behind it
that you have such a certificate.
You're already an expert in this field.
You really accomplish something
significant if you pass.
So yes, you will learn good things,
but no, I do not think that this will make
a huge impact on your career.
Next, let's talk about
SCRUM Master certifications
and for the uninitiated,
the SCRUM master is a role
in the agile methodology of news,
for instance, in modern
software development.
I place this in the C tier for the reasons
that on one side, this is I think,
a skill that is not that narrow.
I think you can apply agile methodologies
in many different areas in business.
Not only, for instance
in software development.
And I do think that this whole trend
towards moving to agile is very valuable
and many businesses cherish
this and value this.
And especially this idea
of being a SCRUM master
is something with some positive
connotation tied to it.
There's several quite
renowned institutions
where you can do a SCRUM
master certification.
As long as you pick one of them.
I don't think you'll make huge steps
in your career only because of that.
But I think it is very
much worth checking it out.
Quite similar to the SCRUM master,
I see the 6 Sigma Belts certifications.
So this is a principle of
an applied in production
It is about process quality.
It is about continuous improvement.
And this is something that I think
many people know, many people know about.
It's a system where you
start with a white belt
and then it can advance
up to a black belt.
I think the last one is a master belt.
It is something that many people know.
I think the 6 Sigma principles
are very well applicable
in many different types of business
outside of production as well.
And people will respect it if you say
that you are a 6 Sigma black belt.
Next to talk about
language certifications,
like the TOEFL, like the
IELTS certifications,
where you prove that
your language abilities
meet a certain level.
And these types of
certifications are actually
often required to get for instance,
into master degrees,
also into MBA programs.
The reason why I put them into the D tier
is not that they are worthless.
Sure they can help to prove
we have one of these certifications.
And then of course you would like to have
a nice high score to
really make use of it.
It's nice to use this,
to prove that your English skills
are really meeting very high standards,
but the truth is also,
especially for these
high-paced career roads
in IB, in consulting,
if applying to a firm
like McKinsey, BCG, Bain,
people will just assume
that you have very good English skills.
It's not really something
where people will test you for.
Some consulting firms do decide to have
just an English component
in one of the interviews,
where they just converse
with you in English,
to see whether you're up to the level.
But if you pass this,
usually you will get the check box
and then it doesn't really matter
how high exactly your
TOEFL score was in the end.
Next, let's talk about the PMP,
the Project Management
Professional certification.
This is the certification where you prove
that you have project management skills.
That you can lead teams,
understand what stakeholder
management is all about.
Master the common project
management skills and abilities.
And this is one where I'd say,
this is very well known, well respected.
People will know usually what this is.
And then on the other hand,
there's also the fact that
in almost all modern business roads,
there will be some type
of project management
expected from you.
This is surely true in consulting,
but also if you work in industry,
project management is just part
of almost every modern business role,
which is, I believe, it
is just very important,
very relevant and also
quite very respected.
So this should justify the A
tier for the PMP certification.
And now let's talk about
another certification
that I will place in the A tier.
And this is the CASE Score.
The Candidate Select Score.
And Candidate Select is actually
the sponsor of today's video.
So what are they solving?
Put yourself on the shoes of a student.
You studied at one of the prestigious
Target business schools
and maybe you score on
the top 10% of your cohort
at this prestigious
Target business school.
But are you now just in general
in the top 10% of business students?
Well, likely not. Likely
you are much better, right?
Likely your percentage will be much higher
because of course there's
already a pre-selection
of students attending this
specific Target business school.
It wouldn't be fair to compare
yourself to another person.
The top 10% of maybe a
Non-Target business school.
And these are exactly the considerations
that CASE wants to solve with
their certification program.
Because CASE is the provider of a fair
and objective evaluation
of university degrees,
both for students and also for employers.
And they do this by collecting
lots of great distributions
for many, many universities and degrees,
and combine this with over
400,000 data points of IQ tests
and personality tests
to algorithmically put
all the grades in the right context.
So with CASE you can get a certificate
as the proof of your actual
academic performance.
Above and beyond just the absolute great.
And the truth is that many companies,
including Boston Consulting Group,
Kearney, Airbus, Thyssenkrupp,
among many others,
they respect this certification.
Actually, encourage applicants to apply
with this certification to the job.
The CASE certificate is currently offered
for eight different countries.
This includes Germany, China, India, Italy
Portugal, Spain, UK, and USA.
So if you're interested
for the certificate,
CASE provided a link for
the Firm Learning community.
We can actually get the basic version
of this certificate completely for free.
Just access it via the link
in the video description.
The free version already gives you
basic understanding where you fall
into the adjusted grade distribution,
some basic statistics around that.
And if you want even more insights,
there's the opportunity to
get a premium certificate
for a small additional sum.
Next, let's talk about certificates
from online learning platforms,
like Udemy or Skillshare.
I personally like these
platforms quite a lot.
I also personally took many
courses on these platforms.
And I'm actually also offering
some of my basic courses
on these platforms as well.
The reason why I put
them here, in the D tier,
is that actually I think,
while you might learn a lot of things,
it's not really respected
in the employer market.
And the reason is that often,
these certificates do not really have
proper examination structures.
And this for me is the difference,
comparing these
certificates to certificates
from platforms like Udacity or Coursera,
where there are proper exams in the end.
These types of examinations
just do not happen
for these types of online degrees.
Which is why employers cannot really trust
that you have the skills.
And of course, the
quality of these courses
can also differ quite a lot,
depending on the
instructor that you follow,
which is why I think
the D tier is justified.
Next, let's talk about the CFI
and specifically the FMVA certification,
which is the Financial Modeling
and Valuation certification.
And yes, this is a
quite industry specific,
function specific certificate.
The reason why I'm mentioning it is,
because I think that many
people actually know it.
Also just beyond the world of finance,
it just shows that you
have analytical skills.
It shows that you are good in Excel,
good at modeling, good in data analysis,
which is why I think that this is actually
something worth mentioning.
And many people also from the community,
on Instagram told me that yes,
they know about the certification.
And they felt that it really helped them
in their application process,
which is why I included
it here, in the B tier.
Let's now talk about certifications
from business schools.
These are certifications
that have recently,
in the last one or two years,
also seen lots of ads on.
Business schools seem to promote
these certificates quite extensively.
You can do certificates on
all types of different topics.
General management, finance, blockchain,
crypto, sustainability, and so on.
And often they're quite renowned
universities behind it, offering them.
And then in a couple of weeks,
for a couple of thousand euros or dollars
that you need to pay,
you will get their certificate.
And let's now start
talking about certificates
that are offered by Non-Target schools.
So proper universities, but
not really Target schools.
And frankly, here, I think
these types of certificates
are not that different from certificates
from platforms like Udacity, Coursera.
The universities are not that renowned.
Yes, it would likely be solid content
because it comes from an
established university.
Often, there's also some type
of examination structure in the end.
Which is why I decided to put them here
in the same tier, here in the C tier.
And let's contrast that from
exactly these certificates
that are now offered from
Target business schools.
So certificates may be offered
by Harvard Business School,
by Stanford, by Wharton.
Any of these other very
renowned business cools.
I think content wise,
maybe they're a little bit better,
maybe not, who knows.
It probably depends on
the specific degree.
Of course, now you have the advantage
of having this reputation, this
big bright name on your CV,
which maybe makes your CV
sparkle a little bit more.
Frankly though, I think that there's
a very significant difference.
Comparing such a certificate
that you maybe make at Harvard,
comparing it to a proper
bachelor degree at Harvard,
to a proper MBA at Harvard.
How this will be perceived
is just very, very different.
And the main reason is
that everyone will know
that actually, you just
paid yourself into it.
Usually it's really not difficult
to get into these certificates.
You just need to pay a
couple of thousand bucks
and then you can do it.
You can write exams in the end.
It's not really considered to be
a big achievement to have done that.
You might learn some
good, interesting things.
And yes, it might give a
little bit of a plus in the CV,
but don't expect that
only because you do that
this will really move your career forward
in a significant way.
That's at least my humble opinion.
Let me know in the
comments, if you have made
any other experiences on that.
Next, let's talk about the GMAT,
the Graduate Management Ability Test.
And this might be a little
bit of a controversial choice
but I do think it's justified
to put the GMAT in the A tier.
And maybe first, for the uninitiated,
the GMAT stands for General
Management Admission Test.
It's an entry exam that is required
for many advanced business degrees,
including almost all renowned MBAs.
And it consists of different sections.
Integrated reasoning,
we need to make sense
of information that is presented to you.
Quantitative skills, we
need to do quant exercises.
And also verbal logic
exercises that you need to do.
So, first of all, I did the GMAT as well.
When preparing for the GMAT for my MBAs,
actually I did learn a couple of things.
I would argue that my
quant scales did improve
quite a bit just by preparing for the GMAT
in a structured way.
Actually I made a video in the
past about my GMAT journey.
I will link it somewhere above here.
Check it out if you're interested on that.
But I do think that a strong GMAT score
and of course, the value
of the GMAT will be
very much determined by this score,
is a very strong indicator
towards employers.
And I do think it can
help you to get the job,
get that interview invitation.
And it's not secret that
many consulting firms
actually ask in the application
forms for your GMAT score.
If you took one, they will want
to know what your score was.
But of course don't make
yourself illusions here.
If you have a score that
is below 650, for instance,
as an image just to provide
a couple of ballpark numbers,
this will likely more
hurt you, than help you.
And then probably from
650 to 700, that's like,
you know it's like not really
good, not really that strong.
Nothing that will really help you
to necessarily get invited.
If you score 700 or higher, this,
I'd say usually will be
considered a good score,
a solid score, where it will
definitely not hurt you.
Potentially then will also really show
your analytical ability,
your intellectual aptitude.
But I'd say to really impress someone,
to really impress someone
with your GMAT score,
you need a score of 740,
750 ideally, or even higher.
And then this will put you in the top 1%,
top 2%, top 3% of the test takers.
This is where you can
really impress people with.
And if you do score above the 700s,
then I would argue for
many, many positions
this will help you quite a lot.
Now let's talk about the one certification
that I would put into the S tier.
And this is the CFA, the
Chartered Financial Analyst.
And yes, this is a
certification that is of course,
based on one industry, on one function
in the finance function.
And it is also true that actually
you can only hold this
certification in the end
if we work for, I believe
in four years or so,
in this area of business,
before that you will not even get it.
But I would argue you don't even need
to have the full final CFA in the end.
Just the fact that you completed
a CFA level one for instance,
or level two or level three.
So three levels of exams,
you need to take level one
level two and level three.
And then this is, I believe, how it works.
If you have level three
and also meet these other requirements
like having a certain
amount of work experience
you will get the title.
If you just have the first
levels, this already shows
that you have very good finance skills,
very good analytical, quantitative skills.
And the truth is, almost everyone
in the business community knows the CFA.
Just a very well respected certification.
Frankly, I look also
at my former colleagues
at McKinsey, what certifications they did.
Frankly, none of them had a PMP,
at least as far as I'm aware.
Almost none of them work maybe
with a SCRUM master or 6 Sigma belt.
Besides maybe the people really working
in the specialized practice in this area.
But if you would look at
the CVs of these people,
quite a few of them had
actually CFAs completed
or at least the first levels.
This is very common.
The truth is also that the passing rates,
actually the failure rates,
of these CFA levels are quite high.
For these certifications
about 50%, five zero
I believe, for the first
level even up to 60%,
six zero, of the people fail.
Just showing that there is
a certain rigor behind it.
That not everyone gets it.
You really need to prove your worth.
Show what you are able to do.
But now all that being said,
do I think that you really need
these certifications
to succeed in business,
to advance your career?
And of course it's difficult
to give black and white answers on that.
It might also depend on the environment,
the company that you apply for.
But I'd argue, especially if
you apply for consulting roles,
also for investment banking.
So these, let's say,
traditional high paced careers.
Actually these certifications
are not really needed.
I can promise you, you will not get hired
because you have these fancy
certifications on your resume.
If at all, if you have a very high GMAT
or maybe a strong CFA,
of course, this can help.
This can underline your
analytical aptitude,
but I've never in my whole life
overheard any people say, oh this person,
this guy, this lady, such a strong person,
just to look at his or her
impressive certifications.
This is just not how it works.
So take all of this with a grain of salt.
Of course also this
ranking it's not a science,
just my personal judgment.
Let me know in the comments,
what your perspective on that is.
Very open to engage in
a conversation with you.
What I think is a nice little offering
is the CASE core certificate
that I talked about.
The firm is actually also
sponsoring this video.
Once again, you can download
your personal CASE certificate
in the most basic version for free.
Check out the link in
the video description
to get access to that.
It is quite respected by several employers
and available in many countries.
So as always, if you took any value
out of this video at all,
destroy the like button, subscribe,
turn on the notification
bell, big, big thanks
to all the members of this
channel, much appreciated.
My name is Heinrich,
you find weekly videos here on my channel.
See you guys next week, until then,
all the best to you and bye bye.